[Music]
we're gonna find out what I'm having
kind of a girl because of course another
meaning uh you know I'm I really do have
but have a girl cuz you guys are gonna
be in trouble
another little me run around pokin
junior right now we have a lot of names
but you know there's a list for a boy
and there's a list for a girl so how
about we find out what I'm having it's a
girl
and I'm freaking so Joe Oh pumpkin win I
think you guys are ready for another
mean I really don't the only thing that
I fear about raising a girl is the fact
that you know she's gonna a day and not
a month doing this she little is gonna
be 45 before she goes on her birthday I
don't think I'm gonna let the baby you
know do pageants cause pies are
expensive and I'm already gonna be
buying diapers
I mean but you know she is gonna be
pretty good she might be a badger team
kind of Ana's gonna flip her because you
know she's the baby girl of the family
and now she's not gonna be no more you
know if you want to follow the journey
of me and my little baby girl
the you have it in me to sit into a mama
Jean not too hot Aaron in January
[Music]
you